die berühmteste Hochstaplerin der Welt
nun soll sie frei kommen Anna Sorokin
und dann soll sie zu uns nach
Deutschland kommen diese Frau die
russisch-deutsche Betrügerin die sich
jahrelang ein Luxusleben ergaunert hat
dahinter hinter diesen Mauern sitzt sie
noch
millionenschwindlerin Anna Sorokin ist
jetzt auch noch Künstlerin
die 31-Jährige Hochstaplerin hatte sich
als steinreiche Erbin ausgegeben und die
New Yorker High Society mit einem
vermeintlichen Vermögen von 20 Millionen
Euro gelingt
nun drängt sich die Szene um ihre
Kunstwerke fast wie in alten Zeiten 20
Zeichnungen und Skizzen stehen zum
Verkauf Sorokin soll diese in der
Abschiebehaft kreiert haben ihre erste
solo-ausstellung als Künstlerin
hinter mir sieht man ihre Bilder die
eben vorgestellt werden bei dieser Party
in einem trendigen Hotel an der Lower
iSight in Manhattan und man sieht hier
natürlich die Zeichnungen als besonderen
Geld hat man sich einfallen lassen dass
eben Models diese Kunstwerke hier
präsentieren sie werden behandelt
ungefähr gehandelt ungefähr am 10 000 $
pro Stück die Bilder sind eine
Kollektion die andersstationen der
letzten Jahre erzählt also von der
glamourösen New Yorker Gesellschaft bis
zu den Mühen des haftalltags
Kunsthändler Chris Martin hat die
Ausstellung organisiert
am besten wäre wenn die Kollektion
zusammen bleiben kann der Gesamtwert
beläuft sich auf 500.000 Dollar
die Party beweist Annas Strahlkraft in
der New Yorker Society obwohl sie
bereits seit Jahren weggesperrt ist mehr
als 1000 Menschen sollen auf der
Warteliste gestanden haben nur gut 200
wurden eingelassen die 31-Jährige
meldete sich dann selbst mit einer
aufgezeichneten grußbot aus dem Knast
[Musik]
ich habe die Zeichnung hergestellt mit
dem begrenzten Materialien die mir hier
zur Verfügung standen es ist für mich
der Beginn meiner Story
wegen guter Führung wurde Anna Sorokin
Anfang 2021 aus der Haft entlassen doch
wenige Monate später wurde sie von der
Zoll und Einwanderungsbehörde ICE in
Abschiebehaft genommen
[Musik]
und dort sitzt sie jetzt eben noch in
abschieberhaft unser Bild
us-korrespondert Herbert Bauer Nebel
grüße dich herzlich wo bleibt sie jetzt
an der sorokine und kommt die wirklich
nach Deutschland in den nächsten Stunden
in den nächsten Tagen oder Wochen
ja es ist natürlich klar dass bei einer
Teil wie einer sourkind wie sie wirklich
heißt nichts ohne Drama abgeht und so
ist es auch bei dieser nun erwarteten
Freilassung aus der Abschiebehaft
zumindest gegen Kaution das würde nicht
das bedeutet jetzt nicht dass Sie Ihren
Fall ihren Kampf gegen die Abschiebung
gewonnen hat es bedeutet nur dass sie
aus dem Gefängnis entlassen werden kann
eben gegen Kaution allerdings die
Auflagen haben es in sich denn sehr
spaßig wird es nicht werden für einer
solchens sollten sich die Gefängnistore
öffnen denn sie muss praktisch unter
Hausarrest bleiben sie muss ja eine
Adresse angeben wo sie leben wird und am
schlimmsten wahrscheinlich für sie
darf nichts auf Social Media Posten dazu
kommt eine elektronische fußmonitor
wirklich ganz ganz strenge Auflagen also
nicht ein kein sehr großer Schritt in
die Freiheit aber einersorge ihn hofft
nach wie vor dass sie hier in Amerika
bleiben kann allerdings ihre Chancen
sind nicht besonders groß für diesen
weiteren Aufenthalt aber wenn man hat
noch mal gesehen haben auch ihre
Grußbotschaft da man hat irgendwie nicht
den Eindruck dass die total geläutert
ist dass sie irgendwie an
Selbstbewusstsein verloren hat dass sie
verstanden hat dass sie gar keine reiche
luxusfrau ist
sie sich treu geblieben und es ist
erstaunlich wie sehr in New Yorker Szene
sie noch liebt es hat sich hier ein
Fan-Kreis versammelt rund um sie man
darf ja nicht vergessen eigentlich so
wirklich ganz berühmt wurde sie durch
die Netflix Serie inventeen einer das
war die zweite erfolgreichste
netflix-show des Jahres nur geschlagen
von stranger things man sieht hier dass
diese Brands der einer delvy der Anna
Sorkin wirklich noch zieht und sie hofft
natürlich das sollte sie wirklich hier
in den USA Asyl bekommen um das sucht
sie ja an in Wirklichkeit dass Sie hier
eine weitere so schillernde Karriere hat
in der Szene da kann uns ein
us-korrespondenten Herbert Bauer Nebel
der auch wartet auf ihre Freilassung und
darauf dass sie dann möglicherweise eben
doch nach Deutschland kommt danke dir
Herbert
[Musik]